[Music]
let's go
thank you guys again okay let's go e4
this time we already gone
we went d4 a couple of times i knew five
gifted
oh thank you i know and okay i'm going
to play an opening
thank you so much anu for verdict city
i'm going to play the c3 sicilian which
i actually highly recommend
to people in the 17 1800 rating range oh
holistic hamster i don't even know what
to do what to say
and we're going to transpose the game
into the advanced french
which i'm hoping my opponent doesn't
play dead man d for the sub
and the move a6 already signals to me
that my opponent
isn't at home in this opening because
this is kind of a pointless move
right we weren't going to really develop
our bishop to b5 anyway
and there's no special way in which to
play this position we simply need to
develop our pieces thank you anu
thank you guys we simply need to develop
our pieces where should this bishop go
where should this bishop go we're over 4
600 i can't believe this yeah of course
d3 is the classic square uh oh
john is in the chocolate so c4 closes
the position entirely of course we'll
keep the bishop on this diagonal
and we will simply continue our
development we don't have to worry about
him going before
um because he's not really very well
developed now
this is a closed position a lot of
people struggle with these kinds of
positions
and i really want to delve into how to
play these positions so i'm going to
make a couple moves here without really
explaining them
and i'm going to explain them properly
after the game but the basic
idea is to identify the side of the
board where we're going to attack and of
course that's going to be the king side
in the center
and we need to figure out ways for us to
get pieces onto squares
where they can be prepared when the
center opens now if we look at this
knight on d2
where i want to get it is actually h5 if
the knight lands on h5 and he goes g6
he's going to get checkmated on f6 how
should we get that knight to h5 we go
rookie one
very typical idea actually i can show
you many games that feature this idea we
go rookie one
and then we slowly begin the transfer of
the knights h5
some of you might be looking at this and
saying isn't this too slow well that's
why
that's why we allow ourselves to do this
because the position is closed
he's not even really open this actually
helps us because the bishop now has very
nice access to this square
another five subs from anew
thank you so much i know i really
appreciate it and guess what he's just
done
he has allowed us to open up the
position knight takes f5
and now a very very important move
very very important move one movement
might first let's go bishop a4
and then after he covers the knight very
important move a very thematic e6
opening up the center guess what look at
how a rook is positioned
look at how our bishop is positioned now
it's time to reap the rewards we take on
on c6 and now there's several things
that we can do
one is to take on e6 which is the
obvious move
but somehow after king d7 he stays in
the game
we can also just position our knight to
e5 and in addition to threatening the
bishop
what does this move accomplish what is
our secondary threat here
and that's really what's going to
devastate him because he cannot cover
both things at once
that of course is queen h5 check
followed by either a fork or a queen
infiltration to f7
that's going to be absolutely deadly for
black
um so this is going to be crushing
and uh he either has to try to cover
that or
yeah so he's covered the bishop but now
we can go queen h5
and remember i always remind people well
actually
we're so spoiled for choice here we can
play knight g6 and win his rook
well let's go for the let's go for the
big money here let's go for a very nice
oh let me think for a second
yeah so we have several ways to
checkmate him here
could somebody propose an attacking move
here yep so a lot of you guys are seeing
this we want to put the bishop on f4
bishop f4 would win the game on the spot
because it would set up a discovered
check
but let's first take on c4 so that we
can then
go bishop f4 with check and that's going
to send his king further into the center
and then we can take on e6 with
checkmate very simple stuff
no need to go crazy okay
and the game is over so he resides if he
if he had got e5
bishop e5 would be may thank you joe
nathan gifting to inaugura
and continues
okay um we had another sub there i
missed from someone
so um since this is probably
a last speed on game for today let's
let's look at it in depth
now where did he messed up right so this
is called the allopin
sicilian i played this opening until i
was about 1900 and then i played it
several more times as a gm
it's gotten very popular even at the gm
level the idea is very straightforward
you want to go d4
you want to go d4 and occupy the center
which is
you know the oldest trick in the book
and black has to do something about it
so our opponent decided to transpose
into a french which a lot of people
don't realize they're doing so e6 is not
the best way to play for people who
don't play the french
black's main two moves are knight f6 and
d5
both of which are very thematic because
black tries to counter strike in the
center
before white gets a chance to play d4 uh
there's a lot of theory there i won't go
into it
but basically that's the bottom line
here there's plenty of places to study
the alpha but i recommend it because
it's so
thematically strong right very classical
opening
now this is the advanced french and the
move a6 is simply a waste of time
which allows us to continue developing
and the main
continuation in the french as we've
already seen several times is to
quickly apply pressure on this crucial
pawn on d4 try to get it to take on c5
and that would basically cause my
central pawn chain to collapse
that's why in the french black often
does this in order to put maximal
pressure on on the pawn on d4
now our opponent decided to close up the
center entirely without developing any
of his pieces
so this already is quite dubious for
black
even though it might not seem that way
right it might seem like black is
completely fine
and this is a little bit hard for me to
sort of verbalize but the reason that
white is better here
is because largely because of the space
advantage and because of the pawn on e5
if you guys look at this bond very
carefully what squares does this pawn
control
it controls these two squares if a
knight ever lands on one of those two
squares
black is going to be completely lost and
there's no equivalent idea so black is
very cramped
this knight is nowhere good to go it
went to f5 in the game and you saw what
happened
so black is super cramped white's got
all these attacking ideas
and that's partially why we bring our
knight all the way to h5
so if he plays f6 that's the other thing
the moment he opens up the center
we see the huge disparity in how my
pieces are positioned versus how his
pieces are positioned
you know that's like the nerdiest
reference ever
i don't know why i came up with this but
do you remember when star wars like i
think qui-gon jinn and darth maul
are fighting and then he like i think
darth maul
forces like i don't know the terminology
but there's like a force field
and there's like a five-minute period
where they're not fighting
they're waiting for the force field to
open back up i don't know if anybody
knows the reference
but basically the way to think about
this position is like that fight i'm
darth maul
okay i liked qui gandun but you get the
point
so eventually the center is going to
open that's just how it's going to be
rarely do you have an entire game with
the center being closed
and when the center opens i'm going to
be better prepared
because my pieces are better are better
placed i'm the better
you know handler of the lightsaber so in
particular i'm applying pressure on e6
and now i can still get the knight to h5
and uh that's basically the way to think
about that i don't know if this makes
any kind of sense
and it's quite general but basically
that's the reason why it's so
hard to play these positions for black
the moment the center opens which
happens
here my pieces just stream in e6 happens
it all plays itself he's got all these
weak squares and his king is just very
unprotected because he's made all these
holes
in his position by pushing all these
pawns out okay he shouldn't have gone
knight f5 that was his decisive mistake
probably knight g6 would have been
better thank you king cookie for the sub
and banded that gifting a sub as well of
course i could have taken here and
attacked this one but it's not
quite as bad as in the game because the
center remains relatively close
now there was no way to stop bishop a4
the square is is very well protected by
white
e6 is super thematic right breaking
through
sacrificing the pawn in order to open up
the position and get my pieces
on key squares remember that when you
push upon
the square in front of the pawn can be
occupied oftentimes very effectively by
a piece
can you go through taking advantage of a
hole well that's actually a very
very important concept the concept of
pushing out a pawn
and then occupying the square that has
been created as a consequence of that
i can show you guys many many very good
illustrative games on that specific
topic
one comes to mind immediately since i
got the question
let me find that game it's it's not a
famous game but i've always
enjoyed showing it to students because
of how thematic it is
so watch uh what white does in the
following position i'm just going to set
up
sorry one sec
um i'm going to set this up on chess
space thank you
require for the prime and the subs
continue
okay so we need to do this
this rousing against bates
so i saw this game i think in a book
by scottish grandmaster jonathan rousen
who is one of my favorite
really one of my favorite authors um he
wrote several very interesting books on
like chess psychology
following position was reached in a game
between jonathan rousen
and this guy richard bates in this was
1997. so in this position roussen did
something very very thematic and very
very instructive
the first thing that comes to mind if
you look at this position thank you
human for the bits
is the fact that black has this bishop
on f6 which is super strong
it's controlling the long diagonal so
rauson wants to shut this bishop down
how does he do it
can you guys apply the concept that we
just talked about pushing out upon and
then occupying the square left behind
bingo bingo literally by the book
now there's a tactical component to this
because if black tries to take f4
notice that the queen is overloaded it's
guarding two pieces at once
we take on f6 we take on e8 and we're up
a rook
so black has to move his bishop out and
then how do we now close the gates
on mr bates so that okay that i promise
i didn't think of that beforehand
how do we close the gates on mr bates we
go f5
and now the knight on e4 is completely
unassailable look at this beautiful
outpost
white's got the pressure down the f-file
and rousen wins the game just by
crushing him down the f-file yeah so he
plays a nice attacking game here we
won't look at the rest of the game
in detail but the attack is absolutely
devastating here
um okay so nicely
done yeah so does this make sense f5
e594 so basically i even did this on the
same
exact file i did this on the same exact
file
uh the e file it's just that the e5
square was the one
involved here not the e4 squares in the
rousing games
knight e5 queen h5 queen f7 we could
have also won the rook here that would
have been completely fine
and now this move is good because it
sets up a discovered mate
but uh we did we decided to make the
second move first
and he resigns because well not because
of this
queen takes e6 would have been checkmate
okay one sec
um sorry with something off here um
thank you dropkick john with a prime
does this make sense
does this make sense or does anybody
have any questions in other words yes
perfect so once again the c3 sicilian i
would highly recommend people consider
this
if you're 1300 1400 it was basically the
first type of situation that i actually
played
okay so obviously i want to play some
blitz
but we've still got over 5 000 viewers
so i would not be against one
last one to round off today's speed run
okay and again i want to make it very
clear
that um okay i think i think i know
where the people stand on this
for what it's good to see people in
agreement i think we need a little bit
more
of that and we have five more
subs from curious chimpanzee keeps the
train going
24 hours a day thank you curious jim
fancy another five gifted
and uh followed by 100 bits
uh amazing amazing amazing over 4600
enzo 24 with a prime
doom is on fire
and flailing fanatical killer man this
app this is just uh
this is just remarkable okay uh just
give me a moment
just give me a moment so
basically grant cardone continuing at
the goonie 132 with the prime
yeah we are approaching a 100k subs on
youtube as well so thank you guys for
that
zoldor z with a thousand bits thanks for
such an instructive series
very happy that you're enjoying it um
awesome thank you for the thousand bits
man
all right one last one here
have i heard anything about pogchamps
three no i have actually not but we will
see
i'm hopeful um
six okay everybody ready
what is your goal dream with this stream
but before i go on um
actually no real goal i mean again i've
only been doing this for about eight
months
full time uh so i i will continue to
balance
teaching streaming playing very
ambitious stuff but we'll see
you know now streaming has taken off so
i've been doing more of that
but basically i'm doing it day by day i
have no no long-term plan
i just want to keep putting out
entertaining and instructive content and
that's
all i could possibly ask for so this is
just the beginning you know there's
there's a lot more stuff
that that that i want to do and then i
want to develop myself in and
you know this is just the opening salvo
okay um
let's go
thank you and appreciate your support
man
okay so we're black against dion reyes
and let's go with another situation
let's see if we can
okay so c4 is is not a great move um
because it weakens and we've already
faced this move once it weakens the d4
square
which we can of course occupy by
developing our knight and if we're
thinking about where to develop this
bishop
should we proceed with g6 as if this
were an accelerated dragon
should we do that
yes or should we instead maybe get the
bishop yeah absolutely we should because
that's conducive to the fact that we are
now controlling the d4 square with even
greater strength
uh so oftentimes you have to decide are
we sticking to the main
sort of the the main setup and
oftentimes the answer is yes
now if you guys remember the last time
we faced this i made a point about
where to develop this knight one
possibility thank you wheels for the
prime is to develop it to f6 but
the counter argument to that would be
the fact that
that knight would then block the
bishop's control of the d4 square
and i pointed out previously that this
knight can sometimes go to e7
this looks a little bit weird but this
is actually a very typical setup which
we are going to adopt in order to let
this bishop
keep d4 under control in fact let's reap
the rewards of that we're going to put
that knight on the outpost
and uh we can support it with the other
night that's part of the reason why i
really like this look at now our two
nights
both of them guarding each other and now
we simply need to
add some tabasco sauce okay how should
we
what do i mean by that well first of all
we haven't completed our development
before we jump the gun on anything let's
castle to make sure our king is safe
and now we have several ways to to
proceed
uh and and this is not an easy position
to play well in
overrated thank you for the prime so one
possibility is to go f5 and try to open
the position up
and the logic behind that is that we
have a beautiful knight on d4 we have
better placed pieces than our opponent
and as we've talked about on many
occasions when we have better place
pieces than our opponent
it's often time to open up the center
this is a risky strategy because we're
doing it in front of our own king
but remember he's also pushed out his
pawn to g4 which has created for us a
hook
how can we now attack this hook with one
of our pieces
very logical this is how you attack we
can attack this pawn on g4 by deploying
what piece boom now he can push that
pawn even further he does
but he continues to overextend himself
and when i say overextend himself what i
mean is that his pawns are going to be a
lot harder to defend
if we can find a way to strike and you
guys
have found a way to strike with the move
e5
you know we're trying to shatter his
defenses this is a very risky strategy
that i'm adopting here it might backfire
i don't think it will but it might uh
because we're also weakening
you know i'm also weakening my position
but if you can see
this knight on d4 we're already reaping
the rewards of that because knight f3
was a huge threat
and um well what should we do now king
h2 is not a good move he's sort of
lost the threat of the game here and the
reason is because he's weakened himself
to such an extent
that uh now his pawns well we don't need
to go knight f3 there's no need for that
we can simply play e takes f4 that pawn
is going to go all the way to f3
it's going to send this bishop back and
then we're going to have queen h3 once
again it's one of those situations where
there's no need to go for something
crazy we can simply take the free pawn
recapture with the knight now aren't we
allowing him to remove that knight from
the board well we are
but uh look at the dark squares now
around his king in fact we don't have to
take back immediately
although probably we should we could
have also given a check first
but his king is completely cornered so
we're threatening queen h4 that's
basically checkmate
in two moves yep and his king cannot
escape to g1
so you can see how quickly his position
collapsed because he just
moved too many pawns out in front of his
king
and that ends the game and
uh basically very simple and logical
strategy that we adhere to now c4 is not
such a bad move if white knows how to
follow it up but he didn't do it very
well
bishop g7 now this is called the botanic
setup e6
right once again the reason that um that
we don't go knight f6 so the knight f6
would be completely fine
uh is because we relinquish partly our
control over the d4 square the bishop is
now not very happy
so we find an alternate arrangement for
the knight it rents an airbnb
you know instead of uh instead of the
bishop doesn't want a roommate here so
we let the bishop
keep its control over the d4 square and
here my opponent missed perhaps his
biggest chance to get out of the
situation
what should white have done here to rid
himself of his main weakness thank you
evan for the 11 months appreciate it
and the subs just keep on going yeah he
should have gone d4
himself just absolving himself over the
weakness now our pieces are very nicely
i like this position for black
because my pieces are super harmonious
the knights are linked
but you know he can develop and we get
sort of an accelerated dragon kind of
position
thank you for the hundred probably about
fifty percent with elliressa
over the years uh i could try queen b6
here but it's not the same thing
i like your thinking though demon here's
the main difference
notice the bishop on e3 in that
accelerated dragon trap
right demon the bishop was unprotected
so here he has complete freedom over to
where
where where to move his knight he can go
to b3 and it's not that queen b6 is that
bad
uh but it could be a little bit more
risky because that bishop is protected
okay comparison is a very powerful tool
to understand position now by the way
we're threatening checkmate here
so that's the consequences of weakening
squares like this
and now the key move f5 right opening up
the position using this pawn as a hook
and a hook is any pawn that's been
advanced in front of a king
and uh he should have probably yeah he's
already
in a tough spot here um i think white is
worse
i don't really see a good move for him
maybe he should have taken here and
maybe tucked his king away
or something like this but i mean this
is already very difficult and now we
just get our queen
and boom e5 striking weakening his
position even further opening up our
bishop
all in the name of the attack you guys
might be looking at this movement saying
something smells wrong right we're
weakening the d5 square
yes we are but we're also weakening all
of these squares in front of his king
you can't make an omelet without
breaking some eggs
and this is a very good epitome of that
so queen to g4
uh threatening a fork because his bishop
is pinned
now we simply take the pawn he takes on
d4 he weakens all the dark squares in
front of his king although his position
is already hopeless because f3 was being
threatened
and of course this is a very simple
checkmate the king cannot
cannot come back to g1 because the
bishop controls
this square what about bishop g5 of
pentagon our queen
well i'm not sure where you're where in
which position you're
referring to
um the the seven deadly chess sins
and um and chess for zebras as weird as
that sounds
uh are both fantastic books on chess
psychology
please explain the prophylaxis of moving
the king to the corner yeah so why did i
say what is the purpose of the move king
h1 why did i say that
this is what white should do great
question well basically there's no
mystery behind this move talking the
king to h1 makes it a little bit safer
why
because the king is no longer on the g
file and the g
file is one of the main arteries toward
the king right you you could see even in
the game
we put our queen on g4 the king is on
the g file and so we threaten moves like
knight f3
so king h1 would preemptively get rid of
various ideas
related to the g file and in addition he
would try to turn this back around on me
and put a rook on g1 and start to attack
me down the g file
so king a chain would be a very sensible
response here
both kings are now relatively safe for
the time being
because they're covered by the spawn
they're not permanently safe they're not
safe in a global sense
but at least there is no immediate
checkmate and there's no immediate
attack
so so that's why i think and that's why
people often play king b1
when they castle long just to tuck the
king away to a slightly safer square
to make it harder for the opponent to
get the attack started
okay and in chess there's different
types of moves there's a time to attack
there's a time to defend
and there's a time to make moves like
king h1 i know people don't like to play
these moves
uh but you have to right you you that's
what makes chess such a complex and
beautiful game
you have to put yourself in your
opponent's shoes and and make things
difficult
for for your opponent and often that
requires making slow moves like king h1
to you know make your king incrementally
more safe so that you have more time to
accomplish your agenda okay let's go e4
and he plays the french so let's play
another oh no he doesn't play the french
let me slap your king
he plays d6 uh so this could be a bunch
of different things he might be trolling
us he might be playing the hippo
in any case it's a good idea to just
develop our pieces and wait for him to
show what he wants to do
now earlier i my strategy was to just
developed as quickly as possible but now
we're a little bit higher rated
so we can take a big a bit of a bigger
chunk of the center
i can show you guys how to do this
responsibly right
now you don't want to do stuff like g4
right when you take a big chunk of the
center
you want to make sure that then you
develop your pieces quickly and you
develop them with an eye
toward defending the central pawns so
right now we're just developing our
pieces
and we are preparing for the proper
moment to strike in the center look how
passively he's developed
okay so this is the last straw
uh because now we've developed most of
our pieces we have a huge center
and just logically speaking goodnight
akilah logically speaking it is time for
us to strike
what does that mean what does it mean to
strike in the center what specific move
am i looking to make
there's actually two different moves
that both accomplish
the same thing yeah e5 is the classical
method of striking then
f5 was the other move we can play that
on the next move if he plays d5
to close up the center which is a very
common response we play
f5 uh and before he gets a chance to
breathe
there we go we go f5 and he is going to
get it
i mean he's he's going to get destroyed
here if he's not careful
okay so well we should take on e6 open
up the position even further if he takes
yeah he takes correctly with the queen
but he's done a very good job here of
avoiding immediate disaster
but he's still in very big trouble now
let's play this
methodically this queen on e6 i'm
looking at it and i'm saying i want to
get this queen out of here
i can't go knight g5 because that bishop
control that pawn controls the square
how can we orchestrate a maneuver to get
rid of the screen on e6 while also
involving one of our pieces which
perhaps isn't doing as much now good job
knight e2 knight f4
another benefit of this move is that we
free up the c pawn which can be used as
a battering ram to destroy the rest of
the center so let's get rid of the queen
and now he's castled long which means we
should immediately draw our attention to
his king
and ask ourselves how can we get to this
king what are the specific
weaknesses on his queen side and by that
i mean we should be looking at pawns
and i look at the a6 pawn and i say oh
that's kind of weak
let's attack the pawn while bringing our
queen into the game we're also keeping
oh
okay um i don't think
this is kind of passive so you only live
once let's go e6 let's strike in the
center again
now what square and we get a chance to
apply
apply a principle what square have we
created for one of our pieces
when you push upon in the center create
the e5 square
now a move like f6 clearly introduces
tremendous weaknesses in this position
what specific square can we occupy
not e5 of course he's defended that
square but in doing so what has he
fatally weakened oh crunch i mean look
at look at these squares
we win his rook he has nowhere to go
bishop g6 would not have been the same
because then he can move his queen
that's still winning for white but this
simply wins material he can't even get a
knight for the rook
he's in tremendous trouble here the
position is he's it's over
it's completely over we just take a full
rook and we've retained
and an item and we win the other rook
his other rook also has no squares
uh because of the pun on e6 this is
quite a comical position
uh we don't even have to take on d8
that's the hilarious thing
and that's the thing that some people
don't always understand is we don't even
have to rush
with capturing on dia because this rook
is not going anywhere so let's first
reinforce our pawn on d4 build a little
pawn chain we could have also taken on
a6 i actually forgot that pawn was
hanging
we should have done that but it doesn't
matter we're up so many pieces
okay now we should take on d8 because he
wanted to go rook ca
and now we can play bishop takes a6 and
win another pawn
now we want to be careful about as i've
explained many times about
over grabbing puns in such a situation
we've got
we've gotten enough now we can go about
winning the game
uh evil fair thank you for the sub now
let's not forget what our initial plan
was
what was our initial plan with the move
queenie too we were trying to attack the
king's side
the queen side so let's continue
attacking the queen side how could we do
that
we need to do that by pushing up our
pawns and opening up files
preferably the a file so that eventually
our queen could land on a6
in order to do that we have to employ a
very typical strategy
okay he's also attacking but he just
doesn't have any pieces left
we actually let's just sack on v5
because we're up a rook and an exchange
so we can afford to sacrifice an
exchange
we shouldn't take on d5 because that
walks into a discovery
there are several ways of winning this
game we could go queen d7
and simply trade queens because we're up
a rook
but there's no need to do that let's
take on a5 and threaten checkmate
so see here it's a judgment call you can
absolutely
you know the simple thing to do and i
think people don't do enough that when
you're up a rook
and you're up a million pounds just
treat queens so you won't give checkmate
in this game that's okay you're gonna
win the game
we play to win the game okay so how
should we exploit the undefended knight
on f5 a very typical discovery
and uh he loses everything here okay
i'm sure we had some sort of a checkmate
but uh why not
why not simplify when we know this is
going to guarantee
the win let's cement the rook
and now we're going to focus on creating
a past pawn as we always do in this
situation
in fact he's done it for us always
you know nothing surprising now look at
the b-pawn that pawn's going to win the
game
we play to win the game okay we're not
going to give up anything here i'm great
i'm feeling greedy
but before we do anything let's first
bring our king in see i know i'm being
pedantic here
but i want to just re-emphasize how
important it is to adhere to end game
principles regardless of the position
that
that you have on the board because that
helps you retain them when the position
is more competitive so we're going to
bring the king in
then we're going to centralize the
bishop and only then are we going to
start pushing our past pawn
glad to hear that x-ray in fact he's
just busted because
uh we don't even need this passport
we're just gonna vacuum up all of his
other puns
the game is over yeah herm edwards
yeah exactly okay he resigns
okay so a relatively simple game because
our opponent just played super passively
in the opening
textbook move e5 followed by f5 ripping
open the center
and um after f takes c6 if he would have
taken with the f
pawn what would we have done here
to capitalize on the center being opened
so bishop g6 is correct that's a very
important check that's also why just
like pushing random pawns
is such a bad idea now some people are
asking how did i decide on
e5 and this is kind of an this is not a
science right d5 would be fine
but the thing is if you look at the c7
square right if you think about
why you would go d5 this e7 square is
very well defended by black so if you
could try to quickly sneak in castles
they don't really want to let black
castle okay
so d5 would have been possible as well
okay so here we go 92 to chase the queen
away
okay knight f4 queen e2 identifying the
weaknesses
if he plays a move such as b5 how should
we have gone about
uh breaking down this pawn chain we
should go a4 that hurts
like hell because if he takes then he
opens up this
if he goes c6 then we can just slam it
on b5 and
this king is just going to be demolished
here so
that's basically the way to attack here
instead he goes knight b it allows this
move
now if he if he would have taken on e6
we could have we could have gone 95 but
we could have also just got knight 26
quite quite
quite like in the game because his rook
is gone and look at this move h6
that basically cost him the game uh well
not written not only that but that was
among the things
that you know that that exacerbated the
situation that's why you should be very
careful as i said earlier
about these random pawn pushes unless
you have a good reason to do so bishop
g6 here
would have also been possible we could
have gone after his queen but
the simple approach is just to win a
bunch of material and when more material
and more material then open up the
position by sacking
and here of course making the simple
decision to
trade queens and capitalize on this huge
material advantage once again
you remain tactically vigilant until the
very end of the game
that's just part of the reason the chess
is so brutal you can lose a queen just
like that after playing a brilliant game
it's happened to me a million times you
know you you let your guard down for a
second
and uh you can manufacture a comeback
with very limited resources which is why
uh you must be vigilant you must respect
your opponent and
and you can never pre you know pretend
that you've won the game or
write one zero on your score sheet
before the game is actually over because
this kind of stuff happens
[Music]
you